Copenhagen's little mermaid statue the
danish capital has repeatedly been voted
one of the top cities worldwide for
quality of life and it's easy to see why
there's lots of water greenery and clean
streets
we start off outside the center of the
office buildings of yokai a company that
sells bike helmets julie otters header
helped create the brand yokai's concept
is helmets that look like other head
where the basic helmet can be
transformed using different covers and
the models offer even more variations
the whole idea is that you we wanted to
you know widen up our target group so
you can actually just wear it as it is
without the cover that is why we also
launched them in in colors a look at the
Euro max reports films back in 2009 the
company was only starting out but it was
already extremely successful and selling
helmets in 12 countries worldwide it had
just won the renowned red dot award and
been nominated for the German design
award they didn't win that one but they
scooped up several other awards since
the Danish helmets have even been
featured in the fashion magazine vogue
the fact that yokai was founded in
Copenhagen is not surprising it's one of
the most bicycle friendly cities in the
world more than a third of the five
hundred and fifty thousand residents
cycles daily
this bicycle counter records each
passing cyclist nearly 2.5 million have
already gone by this year Julie takes us
to one of her favorite shops Phil Orbis
displays its bicycles as if they were
pieces of art along with matching
accessories such as bags or sunglasses
cycling is a lifestyle for some the next
part of our tour is by bicycle thanks to
the city's bike paths you can reach most
of the slides quickly we pass new horn
now popular with tourists it dates back
to the 17th century a malian bore palace
is a royal residence
this is the Royal Opera and this is the
King's garden the grounds of rosenborg
castle where the crown jewels are
exhibited so what kind of park is said
here I think is one of the most popular
packs in Copenhagen generally we have a
lot of green areas in Copenhagen which
is quite nice where people just come and
hang out to meet with their friends and
grabbed it now whatever and play so it's
really nice one of Julie's favorite
restaurants are on jury is on the edge
of the park this is where we met yokai's
managing director Michael Ida the
restaurant is famous for a Danish
specialty smear abrin open sandwiches
with different toppings such as roast
beef or salmon
this is where carlsberg one of the
best-known brands of beer worldwide was
once brewed shut down five years ago the
brewery is now home to offices studios
and concert venues it also features a
kind of adventure playground one of
copenhagen's new attractions on sunny
days there's even a park in this
industrial setting it's been open to the
public since the brewery shut down the
central district of islam's druga is
located on the waterfront it was
redeveloped in the past decade and is
now home to modern apartments and
offices there's a lot happening new
Copenhagen now we have restaurants yeah
all over the city where you can go out
and have really nice dinner all the time
there's a lot of music going on we have
you know creative things just
exhibitions everything Julie artists had
a recently moved to islam's druga
herself she's already discovered a new
favorite bar nearby the bistro addendum
it's a perfect way to end the day in one
of the world's most pleasant cities
Oh